[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
fun
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please join me as
we mark this very special occasion in
prayer
gracious and merciful lord you are the
giver of life the igniter of faith
provider of hope and the author of love
mighty one o ancient of days you have
commanded us to be strong and courageous
in life or in death because you are
always with us
receive your servants most humble prayer
as we gather today to honor and
celebrate three selfless exemplars of
unquestioned commitment and courageous
valor
are thankful for master sergeant earl
plumley sergeant first class alwyn cash
and sergeant first class christopher
slees who embody the sacrificial
willingness
to lay down one's life for their friends
each of these men took heroic actions in
the face of fear and certain death
lord you gave our nation an army the
heart of a special forces warrior to
free the oppressed
the soul of a dog-faced soldier with a
can-do attitude
and the fighting spirit of a ranger to
lead the way
when our nation asked who will go each
of these men declared here i am send me
faith hope and love propelled these men
to display the compassion care and
commitment necessary to throw themselves
into the fray to save others as a
grateful nation help us today as we
bestow its highest honor on these men of
valor who distinguish themselves at the
risk of their own lives above and beyond
the call of duty
bless those that we honor today and i
thank you for the many family members
comrades and arms and dear friends who
are here with us today and others in
spirit to support them
may the actions of these men in the
crucible of combat inspire others to
personal courage
and selfless service
keep the lamp of liberty shining forth
brightly across our nation
and let us all which serve as a beacon
of hope through freedom loving people
it is in your holy majestic and
magnificent name that i pray
amen
please be seated thank you
good afternoon
and welcome to the east room of the
white house
decorated for the holiday season
and uh to celebrate the gift of
gratitude
it's an appropriate backdrop for the
ceremony we believe because our hearts
are overflowing with gratitude today as
we honor the unparalleled courage
and commitment to duty
and indispensable indisputable gallantry
and trip yeah i i it's just hard to
explain
where your
soldiers got the courage they got
late sergeant first class
always cash
late sergeant first class
christopher solis
master sergeant earl plumley plumley
in our nation's newest recipients of our
highest military award the medal of
honor
i want to thank all of our distinguished
guests that are here today
the chairman of the joint chiefs
the
the
secretary of the
uh of the uh
secretary austin
the enlisted adviser chairman colin
lopez and leaders of the united states
army
and the vice president united states and
the second gentleman
and
i'm jill's husband jill is
[Music]
as here add these three names to our
nation's role of honor i also want to
recognize
previous medal of honor recipients who
are here today to honor the brothers in
arms matthew williams matthew stand up
thomas paine
never fired
each of you know what it means to stare
down danger and summon the strength of
the moment of trial
we're grateful for all that you three
have done so many more
the family of sergeant first class alvin
chase
uh has uh has been 16 years this has
been 16 years in coming
representative murphy representative
walsh thank you for your efforts
continued efforts along with the team
sergeant
cash's commanders commander in arms his
medical team and the family
who work with such dedication over so
many years to make this recognition
possible
october 17
2005.
sergeant uh
cash was uh commanding a bradley
fighting vehicle on night patrol in iraq
they came under enemy fire
an improvised explosive device detonated
igniting the vehicle's fuel and
engulfing it in flames
sergeant extracted himself and without
hesitation turned back to the vehicle to
help free the driver and extinguish
flames on the driver
in the process sergeant first class
cash uniform drenched in fuel caught
fire causing severe burns
patrol was still taking enemy fire but
cash thought only of his fellow soldiers
trapped in the troop compartment
so he pushed his own pain aside and
returned to the burning vehicle
and pulled four soldiers free
four more
at this point
with the second and third degree burns
covering almost 75 percent of his body
his uniform emotionally mostly burned
away
the sergeants saw there were still two
soldiers and their interpreter
unaccounted for so went back into the
infirmary for a third time
and got everyone out of that inferno
that was his code
his love for his third infantry division
ran deep
no soldier was going to left be left
behind on his watch
when helicopters began to arrive
he insisted that his troops be evacuated
before he would go
later
at brook army medical center in texas
where he and other members of his team
were taken for treatment
when he regained the ability to speak
his first thoughts were for his units he
asked first thing
how are my boys
how are my boys
alan cash was a soldier soldier
a warrior who literally walked through
fire
for his troops
sergeant succumbed to his injuries in
november 8 2005
surrounded by those who loved and loved
him
he was a hero he was a beloved son and
brother
a proud husband and a father of three
children
sergeant cash and his family gave
everything for our country
the devotion to his memory another year
is working to make sure that his courage
and selflessness were properly
documented and honored
is a testament to the love he inspired
on the legacy left behind
sergeant first class cash is now the
seventh individual receiving medal of
honor
for his actions operation iraqi freedom
and the first african-american to
receive it since the vietnam war
and tamra
alexis
casanova
i'm so honored
to award your husband
your dad
your brother
recognition here
i know it's tough
as honored as you are it's got to be
tough to be here today
you'll be remembered
you'll remember forever
sergeant first class christopher soliz
was an army ranger
through and through
with one
seven five the rangers lead the way
july 12
2018 near the end of the fifth
deployment fifth deployment
sergeant sales was leading an operation
in the pateka province of afghanistan
not a very friendly place
to clean the area of enemy forces
attacked and pinned down by a large
force the sergeant exposed himself to
the enemy fire in order to retrieve a
heavy weapon system that allowed his
team to fight back and reach the secure
location
during the firefight
a member of his team was critically
wounded
as they called for medical evacuation
but as the rescue helicopter arrived and
began taking fire as well
the sergeant knew his time was critical
to get his wounded teammate
loaded and treated
so he once again knowingly and willingly
stepped into the enemy's crosshairs
sergeant soliz used his body as a shield
for the aircraft and his crew against
the heavy incoming fire helicopter began
to take off and he put himself directly
between the cockpit and the enemy
ensuring the aircraft could depart
and sustaining what would prove to be
a mortal wound
he knew he was hit
but he waited for the air crew to depart
without him
in the face of extreme danger he placed
the safety of his team
and his crew
above his own
i can offer no better encapsulation
than the words of the u.s army
ambulance
pilot in command that day
he said quote
courage to me
is putting your life on the line to save
the life of another
as demonstrated by sergeant first class
chris salis
who died protecting my crew and the
quote
christopher selise
was courage made flesh
today
we add his name to the lead vanguard of
american warriors
who generation after generation have
strengthened and inspired our nation
with their unwavering bravery and
service
his legacy lives on
the lives he saved the teammates he
mentored
and the memories he made with his
beloved wife katie
and especially in their precious
daughter shannon
thank you for sharing your dad with our
country
janet
we'll never forget the debt that we owe
you and your old family
august 28
2013
then staff sergeant
earl pumley
was
spam snapping a quick photo
with members of his unit at forward
operation base ghazni in afghanistan
then insurgents turned out detonated a
400-pound car bomb that blew open a
60-foot wide breach in the perimeter
wall
staff stars in pumlin
members of his special operations team
immediately hopped in the nearby truck
and raced toward the blast to defend the
base
when they arrived they encountered
insurgents coming through the wall
all wearing explosive vests
troops
started taking rocket fire the cordless
rifle fire and small arms fire
while the driver of their truck
maneuvered into the line of enemy fire
to shield injured members of their team
outside the vehicle staff sergeant
exited the vehicle and used his own body
to shield the driver
he left whatever cover the truck
provided him and began to engage the
invaders
outnumbered with no regard for his own
safety at times armed with only a pistol
staff sergeant plumley attacked the
insurgent forces taking them on one by
one
time and again
bullets flew by sometimes only inches
away and time and again staff sergeant
plumbling
closed with the enemy
and multiple occasions during the fight
the insurgents detonated their best
right in front of
plumley
at one point hurling him into a wall
and injuring his back
when a fellow soldier was severely
wounded probably immediately ran to the
soldier's position carried him to safety
and administered tactical combat
casualty care before returning to the
fight
ultimately
staff sergeant plumley was able to
organize three polish soldiers to mount
an effective defense of the base
clear the area and regain the security
posture
his heroic actions in the battlefield
leadership gained the recognition of
some of our highest military commanders
including the man who knows a little bit
about battle
our chairman of our joint chiefs general
milley
and general mcconnell
who are here today
who are here today to honor as well
they saw extraordinary bravery when then
staff sergeant plumley did
and they understood the worst outcome
he prevented from taking place they
understood what would happen had he not
done what he did
now
master sergeant plumley
has
this recognition has been too long in
coming
delayed for you and your family as well
and no one no one will ever forget how
you sprang into action
when our when the enemy attacked our
base i'm grateful for your continued
service and dedication to the country
and that goes for your wife terry and
your children lily and lincoln as well
because it's not just the person who
wears the uniform or serves
it's the whole family who serves
sleepless nights
missed holidays empty chairs the
celebrations
the way you give back to your community
english poet john milton once wrote
they also serve
only stand and wait
they also serve only stand and wait
while today we honor three outstanding
soldiers actions embodied the highest
ideals of selfless service
we also remember the high price
our military
members and their families are willing
to pay on behalf of our nation
we remembered strength the sacrifices of
these military families caregivers and
survivors
and we remember
and renew our sacred obligation to those
who serve this nation in uniform
as a nation we have many obligations
to our children the elders those in need
but we have only one truly sacred
obligation
sacred obligation
that's to properly prepare and equip
those troops we send into harm's way
care for them and their families
both while they are deplored and when
they return
that commitment
never expires
and as commander-in-chief
i promise it's a commitment that we will
keep
god bless you all
and may god protect the troops are out
there right now
now it's my great honor
to ask for the citations to be read
and award the medal of honor to sergeant
first class alma chase
sergeant first class christopher solis
and master sergeant earl palmer
will the cash family please
join the president on stage
attention orders
the president united states of america
authorized by act of congress march 3rd
1863 has possibly awarded in the name of
congress the medal of honor to
sergeant first class alwyn c cash united
states army for conspicuous gallatry at
the risk of his life above and beyond
the call of duty
sergeant first class alwyn c cass
distinguished himself by acts of
gallatry above and beyond the call of
duty while serving as platoon sergeant
with company a first battalion 15th
infantry regiment third for grade 3rd
infantry division in saladin province
iraq on october 17 2005. while on a
nighttime mounted patrol near an enemy
laden village the bradley fighting
vehicle which sergeant first class cash
was commanding was attacked by enemy
smallers fire and an improvised
explosive device which disabled the
vehicle engulfed it in flames
after extracting himself from the
vehicle sergeant first class cash set
about extracting the driver who was
trapped in the vehicle after opening the
driver's hatch sergeant first class cash
and a fellow soldier extracted the
driver who engulfed in the flames during
the course of
extinguishing the flames on the driver
and extracting him from the vehicle
sergeant first classes cash's fuel
soaked his uniform igniting and causing
severe burns to his body ignoring his
painful wounds sergeant first class cash
then moved to the rear of the vehicle to
continue and aiding his fellow soldiers
who were trapped in the troop department
at this time the enemy noted his
movements and began to correct their
fire on his position when another
element of the company engaged the enemy
sergeant first class cash seized the
opportunity and moved to the open troop
door and aided for the soldiers and
escaping the burning vehicle having
extracted the four soldiers sergeant
first class cash noticed two other
soldiers had not been accounted for and
again he entered the building to
retrieve them at this time
reinforcements arrived to further
suppress the enemy established a casual
collection point despite the severe
second and third degree burns covering
the majority of his body sergeant first
class cash persevered through the pain
to encourage his
fellow soldiers and ensure they received
needed medical care
when medical evacuation helicopters
began to arrive sergeant first class
cash selflessly refused evacuation until
all the other wounded soldiers were
evacuated first
sergeant first class cast is
extraordinary terrorism and selfishness
above and beyond the call of duty we're
in keeping with the highest traditions
of the military service and reflector
and credit upon himself his unit and the
united states army signed joseph r biden
united states
please accompany the president
attention orders
the present united states of america
authorized by active congress march 3rd
1863 has possibly awarded the name of
congress the medal of honor to sergeant
first class christopher a sales united
states army for conspicuous gallantry at
the risk of his life above and beyond
the call of duty
sergeant first class christopher a sales
distinguished himself by conspicuous
gallantry above beyond the call of duty
while engaged with the enemy in pakistan
province afghanistan on july 12 2018
as the leader of a special purpose unit
comprised of partner forces and members
of the first battalion 75th ranger
regiment sergeant first-class soldiers
led an operation to clear area of enemy
forces and thereby disrupt future
attacks against the government of
afghanistan and allied forces
shortly after his team reached their
final objectives a large enemy force
attacked place effective fire on him and
his team preventing them from
maneuvering to counter attack realizing
the danger the attack posed to his team
in the operation sergeant first class
elise volunteers voluntarily exposed
himself to intense enemy machine gun and
small arms fire to retrieve and employ a
heavy weapon system thereby allowing u.s
and partner forces to regain the
initiative maneuver to a secure location
and begin treatment of a critically
wounded partner force member
as the medical evacuation helicopter
arrived it was immediately engaged by
accurate and sustained enemy fire
knowing how critical it was to quickly
load the casualty sergeant first class
elise willingly exposed himself to heavy
enemy fire to direct and leave the
evacuation
as the casualty moved from a position of
cover and out into intense enemy fire
sergeant first class elise made a
conscious effort to ensure his body acts
as a fiscal shield to his team carrying
the casualty and the crew of the
aircraft
as the casualty was loaded and sergeant
first class seliza's team returned to
cover he alone remained at the aircraft
returning a high volume of fire and
constantly repositioning himself to act
as a physical shield to the aircraft and
its group
with this final reposition sergeant
first class elise placed himself
directly between the cockpit and the
enemy
ensuring the aircraft was able to park
as the helicopter lifted off sergeant
first class soliz was hit by enemy fire
fully aware of his own injury but
understanding the peril to the aircraft
from the intense enemy machine gun fire
sergeant first class selize motioned to
the aircraft to depart rather than
remain behind to load in
his selfless actions saved the life that
evacuated partner force never and almost
certainly prevented further casualties
among other members of his team in the
air crew throughout the entire
engagement sergeant first class elise
significantly changed the course of
battle by repeatedly placing himself in
extreme danger to protect his team
defeat the enemy and ultimately cost him
his life
sergeant first class releases
extraordinary heroism and selfless above
and beyond the call of duty we're in
keeping with the highest traditions of
military service service and reflected
credit upon himself his unit and the
united states army signed joseph r fiden
the president united states
master plumbing we please
attention awards
the president united states of america
authorized by act of congress march 3rd
1863 has possibly awarded the name of
congress the medal of honor to
staff sergeant earl d plumley united
states army for conspicuous gallantry at
the risk of his life and above and
beyond the call of duty
staff sergeant earl d plumley
distinguished himself by accidentry
above me
and beyond the call of duty on august 28
2013 while serving as a weapons sourcing
sea company fourth battalion first
special forces group airborne in support
of operation enduring freedom
sergeant plumley instantly responded to
an enemy attack on ford operating base
ghazni ghazi province afghanistan that
began with an explosion that tore a
60-foot breach in the base faces from
her wall
ten insurgents wearing afghan national
army uniforms and suicide vests poured
through the breach
sergeant plundley and five others
mounted two vehicles and raced towards
the explosion
when his vehicle was engaged by enemy
fire sergeant plumley reacted
instinctively using his body to shield
the driver prior to exiting the vehicle
and engaging an enemy insurgent 15
meters to the vehicle's right with his
pistol
without cover and complete disregard for
his own safety he advanced on the enemy
engaging multiple insurgents with only
his pistol
upon reaching cover he killed two
insurgents one with their grenade and
the other by detonating a surgeon's
suicide vest using precision sniper fire
again disregarding his own safety
sergeant plumley advanced alone against
the enemy engaging several insurgents at
close range including one whose suicide
best exploded a mere seven meters from
his position
under intense enemy fire sergeant
plumley temporarily withdrew to cover
where he joined up with another soldier
and together they mounted another
counter attack
under fierce enemy fire sergeant
plundley again moved from cover to
attack the enemy forces advancing with
seven meters of a previously wounded
insurgent who detonated his suicide best
blowing sword plumley back against the
nearby wall
sergeant plumley ignoring his injuries
quickly regained his faculties and
re-engaged re-engage the enemy forces
intense enemy fire once again forced the
two soldiers to temporarily withdraw
undeterred sergeant plumley joined a
small group of american polish soldiers
who moved from cover to once again
counter-attack the infiltrators
as the force advanced sergeant plumley
engaged in insurgent to his front left
he then swung around and engaged another
insurgent who charged the group from the
rear
the insurgent detonated suicide deaths
morally wounding a u.s soldier
sergeant plumley again without complete
disregard for his own safety ran to the
wounded soldier carried him to safety
and rendered first aid he then
methodically cleared the area remained a
security posture and continued to scan
for any remaining threats
staff sergeant earl d palmer's
extraordinary heroism and devotion to
duty are keeping with the finest
traditions of military service and
reflect great credit upon itself
the special forces regiment and the
united states army signed joseph r biden
the president united states
so
okay
so
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please join me as
we conclude this ceremony in prayer most
holy god as we leave this ceremony
inspire us and lead us to greater acts
of service
may we have the audacity to follow the
examples of the warriors we honor here
today
bless master sergeant
plumley the cash and sales families as
the names of these men are etched into
our nation's proud history
may their leadership and legacies mark
the truest north for us to seek
and may we all strive to be strong and
courageous in the face of challenges
that life may bring
finally we pray that you will give our
leaders wisdom as they serve our nation
and our army's people
and that you will bless and protect the
men and women of our armed forces as
they preserve those precious freedoms i
ask these things in your most gracious
and holy name amen
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
your seats as the president and first
lady and vice president and second
gentleman depart
[Music]
foreign
[Music]